a new era in Colombian politics has
began
I swear to God and promise to the people
to Faithfully comply with the
Constitution and laws of Colombia
former Rebel fighter of the m19 movement
Gustavo Petro swore in as the country's
first leftist president in a ceremony
filled with symbolism and promise of
change
I want to say to all the Colombians who
are listening to me in the Bolivar Plaza
and in all of Colombia and abroad that
today our second opportunity begins it's
the hour of change our future has not
been written
the Columbia of what's possible starts
today we are here against all
predictions and against a story that
said we would never govern against those
who didn't want to let go of power but
we did
the wisdom former housemate Francia
Marquez also swore in as Colombia's
first black vice president calling on
her ancestors for protection
[Applause]
I also swear before my ancestors until
dignity becomes customary
tens of thousands of supporters flooded
the streets of downtown Bogota making it
look more like a carnival than a
political event
I'm here for joy to celebrate what we've
been waiting for for a long time
if petrol can achieve peace then he will
make good to Colombians dignifying the
life of farmers workers and the victims
of this country
Pedro received the presidential sash
from a visibly moved young Senator
daughter of a former m19 presidential
candidate assassinated during the
country's Civil War
and his first order as president came
right after taking the oath of office he
called for the sword of Simone Bolivar
hero of the wars of Independence to be
brought to the ceremony from the
presidential Palace reversing a ban by
his predecessor it carried special
symbolism the m teen stole the sword in
1974 from a museum only returning it
after disarming
Petro joins a new wave of leftist
governments in Latin America and his
plans are probably the most ambitious
aiming to lower poverty and hunger
ending the War on Drugs developing the
long neglected Countryside and
transitioning from oil and coal to fight
climate change
the myth of Truth has come first
Administration will be able to transform
into realities as many promises and the
Hope a majority of Colombians have
placed in him Alessandra Al Jazeera
Bogota